now I have we had a conversation we have
yearly trips to the gynecologist to
check her high you di admits to
attending his 18 year old daughter
daesh's OBGYN appointments to make sure
she's still a virgin
just check the heinie please give me
back my results yep you heard that right
di is clearly one protective father
revealing it to Naza mean mandy and
nadia moham on the ladies like us
podcast
he's been attending his daughter's
gynecologist appointments since she
turned 16 usually like the day after the
party she's enjoying gifts I put a
sticky note on the dough god no outraged
fans are asking how he was able to get
away with such an invasion of privacy
well he cleared that up too
saying daesh's doctor initially
expressed privacy concerns over sharing
the teens medical information without
her consent
doctors maintain a high level of
professionalism he's like what you know
sir I have to you know in order for me
to share information I say Daisy then
what you decide share information you
have is there anything that you would
not want me to know okay seed up front
is wonderful he proudly added I will say
as 18th birthday Hyman is stealing and
social media was up in arms over T eyes
admission one Twitter user wrote I'm
really praying for Wellness safety
healing and good therapeutic support for
T eyes daughter fellow rapper Iggy
Azalea who cut ties with ti after a
highly publicized feud in 2015 wrote in
a since deleted tweet
he has serious control issues with women
in all aspects of his life while a
chrissy teigen jokingly addressed the
situation writing death did not think we
would be talking about hymens today or
TI ET spoke with TI and tiny in 2013
where they opened up about parenting
their six kids when you have six kids
you have to take you know have some
family time so you can just get all your
time in with all the kids show everybody
their attention and you know hey you got
catch them in what they doing see if you
add them later you just let them you
know run off invention and don't never
have to come back or you could look them
in the eyes and smelly fingers person
fingers me oh really yes you can what
you spelling boy i'm submit the
destination neither here nor there yeah
sweet
[Music]